citizens of the rejection it's me Terry
Erickson alongside this guy say your
name wow that was a good job we are
watching Despicable Me which I have not
seen but you have I saw it uh when it
first came out again my rule of thumb is
if I saw it once but don't remember it I
could join for a first time rewatch but
I haven't seen the sequels so I figured
if this goes well we could do the
follow-ups I haven't seen that or
minions or anything like that yeah
domino effect exactly okay well we
better get into it but before we do you
guys need to leave a like you need to
leave a comment and you also need to
ring that
ring the bell oh that felt good if
you're not patrons you should like get
on top of that because you could sync up
with your own copy and watch a full
video reaction with me and Gregory
watching Despicable Me which is crazy
like the entire movie so get on that
super sexy reject nation and become a
patron
now let's watch the movie
I just remember when I saw this the
first time I got into a big fight with
someone beforehand so I was PTSD right
now paying attention
he was thinking about his fight the
first time he saw it I just remembered
that take my picture
[Music]
Justin
reminds you of Sid from Toy Story yeah
just a blown up version yeah
okay stop child stop right there
[Music]
oh it's a fakie I've got him I've got
him
okay
I popped the pyramid that's no good
Great Pyramid of Giza had been stolen
and replaced by a giant inflatable
replica Panic throughout the globe as
countries and citizens try to protect
their beloved landmarks
oh my goodness
[Music]
oh
looking in straight into your future kid
that could be so traumatizing to do a
little boy life is traumatizing it's
about time that I get my way
Despicable Me I like this song this has
an actual theme song yeah all right
hello friend your dog has been leaving
little Bombs all over my yard
you know dogs they go wherever they want
to go unless they're dead oh my God
cookies for sale go away I'm not home uh
yes you are leave a message beep
some fella just stole a pyramid they're
saying he makes all other villains look
lame
Oh I thought they were implying that he
stole it yeah they're just telling him
he's a lame villain now
okay okay
I feel like it's become so easy to hate
these guys but
they are so freaking cute they're very
adorable we installed the Times Square
jumbo
NBC Universal we stole the Statue of
Liberty
whoa the small one from Las Vegas
we have located the shrink ray and once
we take this
God always wanted a shrink ray how cool
would that be I don't want anything
shrunken we are going to steal
he's gonna shrink the Moon is that what
he just said okay lead to the world
ending
yes
I've been crunching some numbers I
really don't see how we can afford these
I'll just get another loan from the bank
they love me oh my God all the banks are
villains you won't be able to see at
night man these first time rewatches are
always so fun for me to see what jogs my
memory and what doesn't yeah like have
you remembered any of it
I'm kind of real life
Edith what did you put on my desk my pie
you're never gonna get adopted Ada I do
not like this lady oh we sold 43 mini
mints 30 taco swirlies and 18
coconutties
oh
look at the photos
oh no let her out or is it almost Tim
burtonesque dark humor to this movie
yeah just so you know Mom I'm about to
do something because my everybody big
when you hear about it you're going to
be very proud
good luck with that okay I'm out of here
cool glasses cool kick mom
nice
I like how the animation has this sort
of uh
1950s spy
quality yeah it's kind of like noir-ish
yeah sort of incredible slant you know
yeah yeah adjacent cruel to see Mr
Perkins oh I get it it's his own
separate evil Bank okay
I know right I thought it was like Chase
Bank and here's our security ball I was
like yeah right weird world someday I'm
going to go to the Moon oh I'm afraid
you're too late son oh the Moon is
personal NASA isn't sending the monkeys
anymore
she loves you on the Inside Man trust me
I know what it's like
poor Gregory I'm applying for a new
villain loan go by the name of vector
that's Jason Siegel because I'm
committing crimes with both Direction
and magnitude oh yeah why is he
thrusting when he says that also Vector
I don't know about that loan in that
tracksuit buddy you have any idea of the
capital that this bank has invested a
new crew view of your Sinister plots
actually turning a profit oh if we don't
start getting our money back oh
I thought he was actually respected I
apparently not by the bank like that
young fellow out there named Victor he
just stole a pyramid oh maybe the
tracksuit is working after all
[Music]
that is diabolical
infant four
no I hope the shrinking doesn't hurt it
can't be violent would it I assume it's
just like oh you're shrunken now and you
don't even realize it right
that does look painful
oh
why is everyone undermine her when he
seems like he's pretty capable
oh my goodness
it's so dumb do you know who voices the
minions I don't know who voices them no
they just like blabber right yeah but
there's gonna be a voice behind it
though
Vector got your back now maybe you'll
think twice before you freeze someone's
head we can't let you give away
[Music]
like how their ships feel like they're
from two different eras yeah
[Music]
great
whoa Overkill yeah why but also taking
one chance on all of them like release
them slowly
adorable
[Music]
what is going oh
at least he's not shrinking
[Music]
wow that could have been really violence
in another movie
[Music]
what he's got a shark dang Factor
Jesus
oh my God
I like the inventions and the
amalgamations of all these like villain
tropes yeah also that he's still alive
whoa
cool cool
we're selling cookies so you know we can
have a better future do you have
coconutties uh yeah
oh Vector loves him coconutties
[Music]
oh my goodness this is what he imagines
that's hilarious you have made a list of
some of your personal achievements
foreign
[Music]
oh
so cute I can't stand it
okay girls let's go
[Music]
my memories was telling me that he
adopted them at the very end
I thought you like for some reason like
like love them and then adopted them at
the end
fluffy donkey
[Music]
an appropriate place for little kids
that's a precocious teenager oh no stay
away from
no well I suppose the plan will work
with two
[Laughter]
oh I poked a hole in my juice box oh I
suppose the plan will work right here
provided everything a child might need
oh my God oh my God no oh no
we're gonna be really happy here right
it's like they replaced one orphanage
for another yeah oh at least the food is
candy how could he enjoy the minions but
not like kids
what's out of these yeah what are they
for
cookie robots I said cookie robots where
are all those Boogie robots gonna go now
[Music]
uh oh she's gonna go to the oh she's not
in there come on I thought she killed
the dog
oh that's cool I would sign up for that
I meant to close that and here of course
is the new weapon you ordered
[Music]
art gun not oh because I was wondering
under what circumstances would we use
this
[Music]
now those are cooking robots that's why
you keep them around
I am a spy may not tell anybody because
if you do
oh no you have to
it has been disintegrated by divination
it cannot be fixed
oh
what is she doing she's gonna hold her
breath until she gets a new one
okay
you have to get the little girl a new
unicorn toy
[Music]
I like how I know it has a name for all
of them Jerry Stewart
watch them and keep them away from me
please they all have like mediocre white
man names thank you Steve Mark Matt
oh my God
it's been a while since I've seen a
movie that is just incredibly adorable
I'm like you're kidding it
[Music]
Jesse
oh karaoke girl get in there
what is the screenplay when it comes to
the minions how do they write that
okie dokie belly bye I get to sleep in
sweet uh no those are bombs
are these beds made out of bombs
[Laughter]
will you read us a bedtime story no but
we can't go to sleep without a bedtime
story she is so cute she's the cutest
thing I've ever seen
foreign
[Music]
oh yes oh my God they look like so much
alike too yes we can't keep the dance
class today we have a big recital coming
up we're doing an excerpt from Swan Lake
yeah Swan Lake
I know that from Black Swan if you want
to go you are going to have to walk
yourself
you're dealing with independent orphans
man yeah man and one
oh
you are coming right of course of course
Pinky Promise my pinky promises
he doesn't know how to love because his
mother didn't love him is that why
you're so broken yeah yeah and
successful
Girls welcome back to the Fortress of
Victor tude you got my cookies for me
oh it is an evil plan to use little
children to be doing this sure is
[Music]
wow
nine are you wearing pajamas
this is a warm-up suit
[Music]
dang those cookie robots are capable of
a lot more than I thought what are you
warming up for super cool stuff you
wouldn't understand like sleeping
like sleeping
oh that's so funny
[Music]
Mission Impossible minions
oh my God how frustrating oh
[Music]
oh
that's super smart I see
foreign
[Music]
I can't quite pinpoint it but somehow
this movie has got me to root for Gru oh
yeah even though he's despicable you
though he's a Despicable Me I I don't
know exactly how they've done it
laughs
well I get maybe it's because he's the
underdog villain and this guy's like a
real dum-dum yeah
drink it
oh if he does shrink it and this is
probably not made in the time of Baby
Shark Song right but that would be
perfect
did they just murder that guy
don't care please please
[Music]
oh man this guy
oh sorry dude they can't ride without an
adult
[Music]
they can't rather than adult but the
three of them could ride in the front of
the car okay that makes sense with no
seat belts
[Music]
On My Feet
oh
oh that's cute oh my gosh look at that
fluffy unicorn
[Music]
oh my god well it is not for sale but
all you gotta do to win it is knock down
that little spaceship there it's check
my prayers voice again
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
scam again
[Music]
come on guys
I feel like it would be possible to win
oh damn
you see how it's not knocked over you
have to actually knock it over
me
fatherly protection get it grow
oh you're the real one amazing what is
that thing
Oh yay love the Unicorn survived
[Music]
I love how you're not freaked out there
by the Let's Go destroy another game
soft real we can't afford any
distractions you would want to see this
[Music]
well done grew rather impressive now the
rest of the plan is simple
things get unshrunk
I shrink them all
I grabbed the moon I sit on the toilet
with what sorry
can we order pizza whatever just get
back in there can we get stuffed crust
I was saying
believe me I am completely focused all
right hello oh no
[Music]
no no no no no
whoops I've seen quite enough
but my plan is a great plan except for
one thing
you oh
look Mom I drew a picture of me landing
on the moon
[Music]
look Mom I made the real rocket based on
the macaroni
ah
there's a random poignant element about
the trauma he has we're gonna put our
faith into a well a younger villain but
it's over but he got the shrink ray oh
my goodness
I'm sure you guys could pull off this
plan without the bank I know there have
been some rumors going around the bank
is no longer funding us I am here to put
those rumors to rest they're all true
they are true you do remember
now would probably be a good time to
look for other employment options
can't you see that I'm in the middle of
the pep talk
that's so sweet
catcher scientists like invent money
[Music]
look at all that stolen money one big
happy stealing family
[Music]
what are you doing here what here he is
what here is all dressed up in his
Sunday best
he looks like a girl an ugly girl
what did you do
things are just better in pink sometimes
[Music]
Mr Perkins your son is here
send him in oh his son is the real oh
okay now it all makes sense do you know
where the shrink gray is back in my
place oh is that right I guess just have
one that looks exactly like it
oh and he knows the three little girls
too
late so Cru sees my latest weapon
[Music]
don't worry the Moon is good as ours
this whole movie is about parenting
the entire movie
well I Empire will you read us a bedtime
story
sleepy kittens what are these puppets
use the money to tell the story
um
Three Little Kittens love to play they
had fun in the sun all day I love this
story
Mommy we're not tired at all their
mother smiled and said with the par fine
but at least you should brush your fur
oh my God he's the mama kitten oh
yes to brush them we feel too rushed and
mother replied with a voice like Silk
fine but at least you should drink your
milk now make them drink the milk
oh
it's Interactive good night kittens
though while you sleep we are apart your
mommy loves you with all her heart
he's realized
real life the end okay good night we're
both goodnight kisses
oh
that is so sweet oh my God
he's not gonna kiss us good night Agnes
I like him he's nice
this family is so freaking cute yeah
maybe we could move the date of the
heist this is not as a result of the
girls dance recital is it stupid I
the weird to
do Saturday
you and I have been working on this for
years they need to go
you don't do something about it
and I will oh no nefario
don't you dare he seems actually
villainous yeah
we put our cups together we will make
the clink sound with our mouths ready oh
tea party he is a little too distracted
by this there's no way he's going to be
able to steal the Moon while also
teaching tea parties to these kids
what are you doing here I'm here for the
girls I received a call that you wanted
to return them what I didn't like what
you said
oh nefario called that is messed up that
is too far
it's gonna make me cry you can't just
return kids okay don't let her take us
Mr Gru maybe in the like Foster system
you can Goodbye Mr Gru thanks for
everything
oh my God no that is so sad I hate it
it's gonna make me cry he's gonna steal
him out of the car I can't handle this
pain it's too much emotional pain
how to go get them back come on
let's go get that Moon the Moon means
nothing without family
that is too cold man he's gonna be so
sad and so is everybody else
[Music]
please
they're racing oh my God she built two
more boxes of Shame I'm gonna put them
in the box of Shame y'all need to build
a big one and shove her in there and do
not let her out
[Music]
I love how it's about him accomplishing
a childhood dream he plays on someone
wanted to be an astronaut the side
though I I am the greatest Criminal Mind
of the century I don't go to little golf
dance recital
they're going to get to you I really
like the way the motion is captured too
in this movie
[Music]
it's like dark and dim that it's all
this movie is still very colorful like
the whole time oh yeah which I love very
Lush colors yeah
squid it to death that's not gonna work
[Music]
oh
that was easy all right see you later
Vector my flight suit
oh yeah once again
[Music]
the way they reflect stuff into their
eyes in this movie is awesome yeah yeah
[Music]
I guess as long as they have the moon
I forget but like
no I mean yeah
I've got it I've got the moon I guess
crew's been to space before because he
seems awfully relaxed yeah
yeah
it means nothing
you're so good people you still make it
to the recital
I can make it yeah hurry
thank you
oh oh no the effects are not long
lasting
oh but how long is the last one that's
what I'm saying I'm like that guy seems
like he was shrunken for like two days
laces no we can't start yet we're still
expecting someone and we just wait a few
more minutes
quick we have to warn him and fast oh
man that Moon's gonna blow up
Studio
okay
I really love the vibe of when this
we're actually with the cities and the
buildings and stuff
oh it's over no he's way late
call them dad
um that's so sad it breaks my heart
uh Vector just big V
[Music]
how is the earth still functioning
without the Moon
[Music]
kids off somewhere I don't know I think
I'll hold out to them a little while
when you are in in the world of pain
how does he avoid this
oh freeze yourself where's your freeze
gun
won't this attack is house this is a
stupid plan
what
no way
all right man oh my God he's getting his
villain skills back I didn't know he
could do that
from the Shadows a hero Rises
yes
[Music]
there he is
at least this guy is actually loyal yeah
catch him catch him oh great timing what
happened to the ship not as big as the
moon's going to be what the larger the
mass of an object the quicker the
effects of the shrink ray we're off
hello
[Music]
hey what are you girls doing back there
how do you not sense any of this yeah
come on vector
[Music]
oh okay yes
run what fun little adventurous
oh cool
[Music]
you're going to have to jump don't worry
I will catch you you gave us back
yeah and it is the worst mistake I ever
made oh
this movie is so sweet yeah
[Music]
okay get Margo
no no let me go
oh my god oh no no no no no no no no no
come on nefario
this guy's so stupid so dumb
oh this is stressing me out man
I don't like it again no
[Music]
yay
oh
yo this guy's gonna get crushed
hey man you wanted the moon you got it
can't kill off people
once again law enforcement is baffled
leaving everyone to wonder who is this
mysterious hero and what will he do next
camera
three sleepy kittens oh no sorry that
that book was accidentally destroyed
maliciously
one big unicorn by who wrote this oh me
uh oh no it's a puppet book
here was this
[Laughter]
one big unicorn strong and free thought
he was happy as he could be then three
little kittens came around and torn his
whole life upside down
that's really sweet
they made him laugh
they made him cry
he never should have said goodbye
and now he knows he could never part
from those three little kittens they
changed his heart
all right good night
give him the kisses yeah
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
all right
this movie is so sweet makes me cry
ah
he's doing a whole Adventure saddle oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
very good
ah I'm so proud of you son what you're
crazy
just like me maybe even
[Music]
better okay
yeah where are those Boogie robots
let loose grow come on man
[Music]
start with the shoulders start with the
shoulders
oh never mind oh okay
full on
foreign
disco dancing was the best
you would know yeah I would yeah I was
like 30 in the 70s
what are you celebrating yeah man he
just likes it up there on the moon
cool
oh that was so good
I cried yeah man
oh man
when she said I love you oh it's gonna
make her cry again I just feel like
coming back up
what's happening
I don't know where are they measuring to
oh
oh we don't get to find out
thank you
was moving a 3D or something maybe it
was
it must be 3D yeah
what a fascinating way to get you to
stick around yeah
there it is ah okay
[Music]
very impressive
looks like Alfred Hitchcock
okay there we have it
Julie Andrews was Gru's mom what Pierre
coffin I have no idea who that is
me neither he's the minions cool
all right I like him
well Tara five stars five five out of
five five out of five five out of five
nine point nine stars out of ten that
movie was fun and so heartfelt yeah like
I wasn't expecting that
I I wasn't expecting
to be as engrossed as you were yeah I
was like just paying attention the whole
time like I I like just being kind of
lost in here I wasn't even really joking
around and watching it I know we were we
were really just watching around more
with this serious movie yeah yeah yeah
that was really fun
I I I I I like how they have these like
little poignant touches throughout with
Gru of this whole thing with his mom and
him not repeating the cycle of his mom
right would actually be becoming a good
pair to you see that all his villainy is
all stem from this place of just seeking
approval yeah yeah but that's seeking
approval is he just wanted love his
whole life and then he finds love with
his children it's such a weird plot it's
such a strange and it's so funny because
like the mom comes at the end and is
like I'm proud of you yeah right just
like added kind out of nowhere a little
bit where it's like oh she sees that
he's become
like a parent and what she was like I'm
proud of you but for what the parenting
thing right that's what the mom was
saying but he doesn't even really need
it right at this point that's what I'm
saying like it's kind of just like oh
whatever it's we've gotten over that now
Mom like I know now what true love is
which would mean they accepted him from
day one which any other kid would be
like you're scary and this is weird and
they were just like hey you want to hang
out you want to play with us I mean
especially Edith if it's our character
like the entire house because she's like
the weird kid she's like me when I was a
kid
um but uh I I liked that I think the the
theme yes parenting but also like true
love because they showed him that from
day one they never like judged him it
was always just like they they just saw
him for what he was and welcomed like
whatever he brought to the table with
Open Hearts and open minds yeah they
just wanted a parent they just wanted a
parent right yeah but I like the dark
sense of it's not like a dark humor but
there's a I would say dark in the way of
how people say
not even quite this much but like an
Adam's family kind of dark where it
doesn't feel dark there's a Macabre kind
of humor to it yeah where it's it's not
the typical kind of kids humor you would
expect where they're they're willing to
touch on at like the way they make fun
of the whole orphanage side of things
yeah or how how much Guru does like to
bully or how he wishes ill will you know
yeah I think a lot of that was was
really funny and uh and kind of
refreshing I really I I I sincerely uh
incorrectly remembered it I thought that
it for some reason my mind I remembered
that Gru wanted to be a super villain
and
something with the little kids and my
mind was telling me that he adopted them
at the very end of the movie
and I guess he kind of did adopt him
because he returned them so maybe that's
what my mind was telling me was like he
got the method but I I feel like if you
get them the second time you're like
you're keeping them
but this whole thing with this Vector
guy and and and uh using the kids as a
ploy to be able to get them that not a
single recollection of so most of this
did feel like pretty bright like a brand
new film yeah yeah it felt like very
brand new to me and uh weirdly I I
wonder if
I feel like when did this come out do
you have any idea anyway I don't I'm
assuming like early 2000s let me see if
we can say my God that's so loud I hate
that noise
let me see here it'll probably say right
it should 2010 2010. I honestly feel
like at I mean uh
uh I I imagine I would have liked it but
man it's amazing how much I can forget I
mean I can watch a movie like one time
like from a few years ago and or like
and not remember right it's kind of wild
right yeah be like wow it it shocks me
how how little my memory
information mine is also very bad yeah
yeah well 2010.
I wanted to watch my words doesn't
remember 2010. because it was a kid's
movie but 2010 Greg was doing a lot Greg
was weird in 2010. he wouldn't have
understood this movie Greg was
definitely using a lot of things that
started with a W it ended with a d you
know what I mean so oh yeah yeah yeah so
yeah I
[Music]
what is that what is that thing in in on
our memory no you know what I mean but
like how come we can't
remember anything like with a movie it's
just bizarre to me how how little like I
can like see an image of something and
be like I know what that's from but then
if you want to know details oh I can't
remember but don't you feel like
probably everyone else on this channel
or most people we know would be like oh
it's that and don't you remember this
plot and this plot and then this line
from this movie and I'm like I watch a
lot of movies and a lot of TV shows and
I cannot quote any of them I can't tell
you what I watched last month I would
literally have to go back to be like
what's my viewing history and then I can
let you know because that was so
engrossed in this and I was so affected
by this movie too and I'm like I don't
recall granted I remember to get into a
fight with someone before this movie but
I don't recall being affected at all at
all I didn't even recall my any
emotional uh uh attack I was like I
think it was funny that's what I
remembered my mind saying was like I
remembered it being funny I don't
remember my heart actually being really
touched by it and maybe 2010 Greg just
wouldn't be you were just like too high
and or asleep yeah I was too cool for
school man yeah man he wasn't gonna cry
no way would you catch him doing that
arms folded I punched the person next to
me exactly here uh but no 20 23 Greg
would uh he would cry I'd cry he brings
tissues I was that was so that was a man
bag so he can put tissues real men cry
or
or or they can get out real men cry or
they can get the hell out get out yeah
that's what you're saying that's what
I'm saying we're saying I can get out no
I'm saying what are they what do you
mean get out what am I getting men can
cry or they can say it together get the
heck out what I thought we were gonna
say it together but nope it's fine
moments over we lost the train of
thought uh anyway that was a little
commentary it's a great film what was
your favorite moment of this movie
Gregory tell the people please who was
the I love you did you have a favorite
moment here oh oh my god
um it's so fluffy I want to die oh my
god when she calls the unicorn and she
says it's so fluffy I want to die that
is my favorite line I love it so much
but yes obviously I mean it's like when
he I don't yes when he goes and gives
him kisses and then they all line up and
he's like a full-on dad slash parent now
and villaining doesn't mean so much now
yeah he's gonna that takes a villain
takes a back seat to be in a cool parent
you know what I what you think of the
animation because the animation to me
was interesting because I like I like
the aesthetic Choice a lot of the the
Espionage old Flair to it that that felt
like out of a 60s cereal or something
like that yeah um like not Mission
Impossible today but Mission Impossible
back the TV show you know yeah wow yeah
that kind of old school vibe to it or
like Bond you know from the 60s yeah and
so I like the aesthetic but I also
thought The the actual dimensions of
things is relatively simple you know
like it doesn't seem like it's trying to
be this overly flashy anime like it's
still vibrant yeah like there's
something that's still simple about the
way it was done and yeah there's no like
real wide shots or anamorphic type like
or a crane or like a dolly where it's
like it keeps moving it's just sort of
like basic tattoos Fields yeah yeah or I
don't want to like slide it no I think
it works for the story oh yeah yeah it
works it works so well that you don't
notice it until you think about it by
going like oh they could have tried too
hard and and put in a lot of like moving
shots or shots that take a long time but
it was more just like it was more basic
in the way that it was delivered which
obviously still worked you know what I
liked about the structure too that I
thought was unique was that the
normally a story like this where you
have a very specific world you usually
have some type of Cipher for the
audience some who they can hand the
exposition do you like you explain it to
them so as they're walking through the
store and they don't have that right
they just thrust you into the the story
in the world and you're learning as a
like like with the bank like I got to
get it from the bank and we're either
being a character being like go to the
bank yes there's a villain for the bank
there's no one there's a villain Bank
through this
yeah that's like how BBC does it any
good TV shows
it is
they do zero Exposition they're just
like we trust the audience let them
figure it out which I wholeheartedly
appreciate yeah BBC does that well and
they did that well here what'd you think
of vector
I mean he was fine I mean he was once
you were like it's Jason Siegel I was
like he's hilarious like I liked the
voiceover but um he wasn't like
he was a character that if I thought of
this movie I wouldn't really think about
him at all I would think about the three
girls yeah and uh and Guru and the
minions and that's it and I'd be like oh
there was some other guy there when a
orange tracksuit yeah not a very
memorable character not really right
yeah I had no recollection I was like
okay yeah like oh he's in this but yeah
yeah it was necessary to have in it
right for someone to him to fight
against but I didn't I didn't I don't
know I didn't feel very strongly about
him exactly that's probably the best way
to put it I didn't really I if there's
anything I could have used a bit of an
enhancement I thought maybe maybe right
yeah like I like what they set up too
with him having the the juxtaposition of
the guru with his mom and then vector
and his dad
I felt like there was something
thematically happening yeah
um but yeah it was very two-dimensional
oh that makes me think that like when
the girls were there with Vector what if
they had like changed him his character
in the moment if they had been there
enough time touched him in the same way
that they touch grew in regards to
making
um Vector think a little bit differently
not so differently that he wouldn't want
the moon back but maybe a little bit
like they could have had because Vector
obviously has similar problems with his
bank dad right like he's feels inferior
um so in you saying that I thought like
oh it would have been cool if there was
a way that
um I don't know maybe the girls have
affected him in some certain way with
like one little piece of information and
sort of made Vector wake up to go like
what do I actually like want to do I
don't know yeah like that's true I don't
know how they could do that but maybe
maybe and the girls were really adorable
I they're so cute the relationship was
great I like how I like the way how they
they did Bond it went down a direction I
didn't expect because it was
it was playful and started off with
annoyances was like it has the
trajectory that you could see on like an
outline of something but the way they
landed there like I like how it led it
started happening after he got to be
himself with taking out his big Arsenal
weapon and shooting down that that space
thing in the oh yeah yes Carnival thingy
and yeah that that opened the door for
them to actually Bond yeah because he
saw that they would love him even though
he is like a villain with real guns yeah
they never viewed him as a villain or
even questions no they were just like
cool yeah I thought that was great those
kids were cool I wonder what the sequels
are about
hmm because you got to keep the steam
going in some way right yeah I mean
Vector is still alive on the moon so is
he still or no he probably won't come
back we got a super villain world so we
got it there's like many we gotta get
rid of actor there's a new villain there
used to fight right yeah we got to get
some new buildings what if the girls are
like they're like little mini super
villains now but they're like they're
nice they keep him grounded like they
but they make him fight for the right
things instead of the bad things like
not shrink the moon this person's mean
or like you gotta go save these people
right they teach him to do be like a
good hero
yeah you know I just realized the movie
that was so smart actually
um
was they they plant the seed right away
with his change of heart other than like
you you could see it coming just because
of the kids movie that he would have a
change of heart it's his relationship
with the minions because the minions are
so childlike and you could see that he's
very much endeared to them as well he
doesn't just even though they're called
Minions he doesn't just treat them like
henchmen you know right they're all
named he he likes he likes to get the
good attention from them he shows them
love Yeah and even though they're not
human they're childlike so that is I
think there's like a subconscious
endearment because I could I kept trying
to place like why am I liking this guy
why am I why am I rooting for him
because he called and you did initially
call it out when you were like he knows
their names yeah yeah it was really odd
to me I was like it's kind of weird how
they all like there's this large
quantity of them and he knows them all
by name right yeah like when he started
naming them that may be like I didn't
notice it until you said something and I
was like oh yeah and then I realized
they're all like Mark Steve John
um yeah yeah yeah but I think that is
sort of the subconscious thing of like
him at least knowing their names that
shows that he he cares he's not a total
jerk oh yeah right I like the old guy
too I thought it was gonna be like a
full villain nefario yeah they did a
good uh job of like riding the line of
like is nefario just a full-on jerky
pants especially when he called in the
kids to be like send them back you're
like what the f but then he he does come
through for his friend and he saves them
which is nice and I think like obviously
maybe in the second one nefario probably
builds a relationship I would assume
with the girls and now it's like one big
happy family he's realized like these
girls are cool well I'm excited
um to check out the the other ones uh
even though I like the minions a lot in
this part of me is having a hard time
wrapping my brain around a whole movie
just about the minions
like what would that
I mean because there's this there's this
thing that's happened in the Zeitgeist
of the world where minions are loved
obviously this was their introduction
yeah and then a lot of people I think
they they just started getting like
promoted and shoved and became like the
the mascot yeah like Universal Studios
and illumination everywhere so people
started getting really annoyed by them
yeah
um
so I keep wondering if the movie will
just be annoying but we'd have to find
Despicable 2 or you mean minions there's
like an actual movie Minions it's just
about like the minions like a prequel I
don't know if I've seen it I don't think
I have I definitely haven't seen it I I
haven't seen it there's like two like
just Minions movies
that were like released in the theaters
and we're like the only thing I know is
that is I know that because I've been to
Universal Studios and they said it a lot
and I always thought it was funny and
I'm always like banana I hated that
that's what I know
hell well well well well I don't it's
not my favorite ride either anyhow uh we
love you all and what do I say at the
end uh what did you think about
Despicable Me should we watch the
sequels guys you let us know what you
thought about this movie and also let us
know if we should react to the other
ones right very good did I do he's yeah
Bingo baby and also I mean if you
haven't I know what he's gonna say he's
trying out but I was gonna say if you
aren't already a super sexy Patron you
should become one you know yeah like
I see you you see us Patron it up
Patron shout out here we go I want to
shout out Chris wamoth oh the reason why
is because this movie is about adoption
and if there's someone at our patreon
I'd like to adopt to be Chris whamla oh
because this guy is insanely selfless
he's one of those those like Warriors in
the street who's been arrested for
fighting for people's rights wow Chris
he's a great guy and you want to have
someone like that
as your child yeah absolutely because no
matter how crappy you treat that kid
they'll be nice to you they'll be nice
and they will always find a way to be
like I I know it comes from a place of
love Daddy Greg yeah and uh I'd want to
be called daddy Greg too that way it
sounds like there's something creepy
going on
then I'm like no there's nothing creepy
happening with Chris and I that's my son
and be like well why do you have him
call you Daddy Greg it sounds like
there's there's some kind of Oddity
happening here like that's just what he
calls me because I want him to call me
that yeah anyway
um
Chris I would love to adopt you my
friend and I think that you would be the
ideal candidate for inheriting real
rejects really wow I mean I am literally
sitting right here well
let's just face it if if a woman were to
take over
well Daddy Gregory I've really I've
heard enough I could score some brownie
points actually with the public yeah
because I'm a lady because I look very
Progressive yeah because I'm a lady so
let me consult with the other men okay
yeah see if that's go into your room
full of men and see if they want a lady
to run the real Rejects
I bet you're gonna get a lot of comments
and people are gonna be like let that
lady run it and some people are gonna
call me a woman and some people are
going to be like we don't know this girl
but she might seem okay is it defensive
to say lady
why I called myself a lady okay just
making sure oh lazy
a woman a lady
you know I don't know we lost Greg I
don't know just like tell Chris you love
him so we can all go eat dinner now I am
so hungry
happy Birthday Chris it's late we love
you Chris I'm so glad he adopted you
before he even thought about adopting me
and I'm here all the time
now here's why we say goodbye yeah okay
bye
illumination banana
foreign